[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
paris einen schönen guten abend und
herzlich willkommen zu knapp 20 minuten
nach rechnen mit dem sport klar und mit
norbert könig vor sehr gerne guten abend
blicken wir auf unsere großen themen
dieser sendung
heftige angriffe im osten der ukraine
russische truppen versuchen die region
luhansk vollständig unter ihre kontrolle
zu bringen
demonstration für schnelleren
wiederaufbau ein jahr nach der
flutkatastrophe im aartal fordern die
menschen mehr unterstützung
und die schweinepest breitet sich aus in
niedersachsen muss ein betrieb seine
tiere keulen fast 300 betriebe liegen
der sperrzone
die siegchance ist die letzte große
stadt im gebiet lohans unter
ukrainischer kontrolle seit wochen wird
dort gekämpft jetzt soll das russische
militär ließ die chance nach eigenen
angaben ganz umzingelt haben die
eroberung von lohans ist eines der
erklärten kriegsziele russlands der
berater des ukrainischen präsidenten
spricht von einer neuen taktik der
russischen armee wohnviertel zu
attackieren ein bericht von luhden
liners
pro-russische kämpfer und journalisten
wissen die russische fahne im
stadtzentrum die einzigen aufnahmen aus
musik tanzt heute ihre botschaft moskaus
truppen haben die stadt unter kontrolle
die lizenz mittlerweile aussehen dürfte
lassen diese aktuellen bilder erahnen
sie zeigen die bereits eroberte
zwillingsstadt severo donets direkt
gegenüber
von völliger zerstörung berichten
geflüchtete diesen letzter minute
ausließ chance heraus geschafft haben
die stadt existiert praktisch nicht mehr
sie ist so gut wie ausgelöscht von der
erdoberfläche
von einer russischen vernichtungs
strategie spricht auch der gouverneur
und bestreitet zugleich dass lucy jones
von den angreifern bereits eingekesselt
sein
an tag 1 129 des krieges konzentrieren
sich die kampfhandlungen auf die ost
ukraine die städte saratow netz konnte
sie tanzt sind weitgehend zerstört nun
sind vor allem die städte aktiv
nikolajew und mahmut ziele russischer
angriffe besonders viele tote hat
offenbar die stadtbach mut zu beklagen
von luftangriffen mit hochpräzisen
waffen spricht das russische
verteidigungsministerium
bei dem angriff habe man 120 ukrainische
soldaten ausgeschaltet ziel sei ein
militärlager der ukraine gewesen
auf dieses video ging der
militärsprecher nicht ein es soll
phosphorbomben zeigen abgeworfen über
der schlangen insel im schwarzen meer
beschuldigungen von ukrainischer seite
die heute nicht überprüft werden können
erst vor wenigen tagen hatte sich
russland von der strategisch wichtigen
insel zurückgezogen
aufnahmen der deutschen panzerhaubitze
2000 heute in sozialen netzwerken sie
sollen die von deutschland und den
niederlanden gelieferte haubitze im
einsatz in der ost ukraine zeigen
protest gegen die hohen kosten des
krieges in der ukraine und die
aufrüstung in deutschland gab es heute
in berlin mehr als tausend menschen
gingen dort auf die straße unter dem
motto wir zahlen nicht für eure kriege
forderten sie eine andere zeitenwende
die 100 milliarden euro für die
aufrüstung der bundeswehr sollten besser
in demokratische zivile und soziale
projekte investiert werden aufgerufen zu
der demo hatten friedensinitiativen und
linke gruppen
der präsident der bundesnetzagentur
fürchtet einen totalausfall russischer
gaslieferungen
die frage sei ob aus der bevorstehenden
regulären wartung der erdgasleitung nord
stream 1 zitat eine länger andauernde
politische wartung wird sagte klaus
müller der funke mediengruppe müller
rief daher alle haus- und
wohnungsbesitzer auf ihre gas
brennwertkessel und heizkörper rasch zu
prüfen und effizient einstellen zu
lassen
steigende corona instanzen wieder merkur
wird erkrankte auf den intensivstationen
und die lage könnte sich nach
einschätzung von gesundheitsminister
lauterbach noch verschärfen wir stehen
vor schweren wellen im herbst und winter
sagte er im zdf man wolle jetzt schnell
das infektionsschutzgesetz überarbeiten
der städte und gemeindebund fordert
spätestens für den herbst wieder
kostenlose bürger tests
fast ein jahr ist es jetzt her eine
hochwasserkatastrophe trist vor allem
das aatal in rheinland pfalz allein dort
starben 134 menschen außerdem zerstört
die meter hohen flut tausende häuser
aber auch straßen brücken und schienen
seitdem versuchen die betroffenen ihre
welt wieder einigermaßen in ordnung zu
bringen aber an vielen stellen dauert
der wiederaufbau quälend lang und
etliche menschen die dort leben fühlen
sich auch zwölf monate nach der albtraum
nacht vom staat alleine gelassen an den
sternen
unterwegs in den spuren der todesflug
jeden tag ist heinz hoffmann in seinem
alten fachwerkhaus wohnen kann er hier
nicht das gebäude komplett entkernt seit
einem jahr seit der katastrophe
seitdem bekam er viel private hilfe
unbedingt brauche er aber endlich geld
aus dem staatlichen wiederaufbau vor um
sein heim zu sanieren
traurig
sein antrag bei der zuständigen bank des
landes rheinland pfalz in bearbeitung
heißt es seit monaten
zu langsam zu bürokratisch sei der
wiederaufbau so die kritik die lauter
wird
heinz hofmann und viele andere aus dem
ahrtal betroffene auch helfer heute in
mainz protest vor dem landtag wir wollen
auf jeden fall unser alter so schnell
wie möglich ausbauen wir wollen
verhindern dass die leute noch jahrelang
in baustellen ruinen sitzen die
landesregierung sagt die anträge für
zahlungen aus dem wiederaufbau fonds
seien so einfach und schnell wie eben
möglich 200 millionen euro für die
sanierung von häusern stand jetzt
bewilligt heinz hoffmann hat noch nichts
bekommen lebt im wohnwagen direkt neben
seinem kaputten zu hause
5 in zukunft ein landhaus vergangen und
ich da auf wo ein ganz normales leben
wieder aufnehmen
seit einem schlaganfall vor acht jahren
sitzt er im rollstuhl die fluten hat er
überlebt bis zum bauch im wasser im
ersten stock seines hauses in dass er
noch lange nicht zurück kann
in den usa tobt ein kampf um das recht
von frauen abzutreiben nachdem der
oberste gerichtshof vor gut einer woche
das abtreibungsrecht kassiert hat
versuchen immer mehr bundesstaaten ihre
gesetze zu verschärfen google hat daher
jetzt angekündigt künftig die standort
daten von nutzern zu löschen die eine
abtreibungsklinik besucht haben zum
schutz vor strafrechtlichen ermittlungen
denn die drohen jetzt zum beispiel
frauen in florida an der fast ein
sicherer hafen das war florida bis
gestern 80.000 frauen haben letztes jahr
hier abtreiben lassen doch nun da der
oberste gerichtshof das liberale
abtreibungsgesetz gekippt hat wird auch
hier verschärft abtreibungen sind nun ab
der fünfzehnte woche verboten die
begründung emotional aufgeladen vom
republikanischen gouverneurin des amtes
das sind ungeborene babys mit herzschlag
die spüren schmerz und nuckeln am daumen
dass unser gesetz erlaubt sie
auseinanderzureißen das halte ich
einfach nicht für richtig
des amtes hat viel vor als möglicher
präsidentschaftsanwärter für kultur
kampf in florida das neue gesetz hatte
er bereits im april vorbereitet es sieht
auch keine ausnahmen vor für opfer von
vergewaltigung und inzest widerstand
formiert sich nicht nur auf der straße
ein richter ordnete gar eine
einstweilige verfügung an
ich stelle fest dass der staat nicht
durch überzeugende beweise nachgewiesen
hat dass dieses gesetz habe er fünf ein
zwingendes staatliches interesse
darstellt das es zu schützen gilt so
könnte ab dienstag das neue gesetz
ausgesetzt werden allerdings wohl nur
vorübergehend und die demokraten in
washington können bisher kaum einfluss
nehmen da sie nicht genug stimmen im
senat haben und so kein durchkommen in
den kongress ein versprechen hat
präsident beiden dennoch wenn
extremistische gouverneure versuchen
eine frau zu hindern aus ihrem start der
ihr verbietet medizinische hilfe zu
suchen in eigenen staat zu reisen der
diese hilfe anbietet wird die regierung
handeln um ihr grundrecht zu schützen
bundesstaaten in denen abtreibungen
weiter in vollem umfang erlaubt bleiben
etwa new york und kalifornien rüsten
sich nun für einen erwarteten ansturm
gegen schlechte lebensbedingungen und
politischen stillstand sind in libyen
tausende menschen auf die straße
gegangen auch in der hauptstadt tripolis
in tobruk im osten des landes stürmten
demonstrierende das parlament und legten
feuer libyen ist seit dem sturz von
langzeitherrscher viel vor mehr als zehn
jahren vom chaos und gewalt geprägt
seitdem ringen zwei rivalisierende
regierungen und bewaffnete milizen um
die macht
im iran sind bei einem schweren erdbeben
mindestens fünf menschen ums leben
gekommen mehr als 80 wurden verletzt
die erschütterung hatte eine stärke von
6,0 und trafen die provinz urusgan im
süden des landes doch behörden gab es
mehrere nachbeben
in fast 30 dörfern fiel der strom aus in
der region kommt es immer wieder zu
erdbeben
dort treffen mehrere kontinentalplatten
aufeinander
und in der gleichen gefährdeten region
liegt auch irans nachbarland afghanistan
erst vor zehn tagen gab es dort ein
heftiges erdbeben
es trifft mit der stärke 6,1 den osten
des landes vor allem die bergdörfer in
den provinzen noch host und praktika
mehr als 1000 menschen sterben
mindestens 1600 werden verletzt
und weil die provinzen abgelegen sind
kommt hilfe noch immer nur schleppend an
wie er berichtet
sie haben zumindest ein zelt über dem
kopf auch viele tage nach dem beben
warten die menschen in den entlegenen
bergregion auf hilfe ihre häuser liegen
in trümmern müssen vor dem winter wieder
aufgebaut werden wie das von l'aquila
sacchi auch er hat in seiner familie
tote zu beklagen
in diesem haus habe ich sechs
familienmitglieder verloren darunter
meinen bruder
seine kinder waren zwölf und acht jahre
alt mein sohn war gerade ein jahr
insgesamt starben hier drei erwachsene
und drei kinder
auf schlechten straßen erreichen
hilfsgütertransporte die dörfer die
hilfe wird von örtlichen behörden
verteilt unter aufsicht der taliban die
übten einfluss auf die verteilung
kritisieren un-vertreter und verurteilen
auch die anhaltende unterdrückung von
frauen im land
die de facto regierung versprach bei
meinem besuch im märz ihre
menschenrechts verpflichtungen
einzuhalten so weit sie mit der scharia
vereinbar seien trotz dieser zusagen
sehen wir den anhaltenden ausschluss von
frauen und mädchen vom öffentlichen
leben und ihre systematische
unterdrückung
besuch der taliban-führung in der
betroffenen provinz paktika vor einigen
tagen mädchen oder gar frauen sind auf
diesen bildern die das zdf team vor ort
drehte nicht zu sehen das thema
schulausbildung für mädchen sei
schwierig und müsse gelöst werden hieß
es heute aus kabul doch das sagen die
taliban werde wohl noch einige zeit
brauchen
zurück nach deutschland
die afrikanische schweinepest hat jetzt
auch niedersachsen erreicht erstmals ist
sie dort in einem betrieb nachgewiesen
worden ausgerechnet ein bundesland also
wo es besonders viele dieser
mastbetriebe geht
landwirtschaftsministerin autokinos
sprach von einem emotionalen schlag für
die schweinehalter im land nun ist der
betroffene hof weiträumig abgeriegelt
manila hier im emsland leben viele höfe
von der schweinezucht noch weiß niemand
wie es passierte aber die gefürchtete
afrikanische schweinepest ist in diesen
steige lang hausschweine sind infiziert
nun muss der komplette bestand
1780 schweine und ferkel
tierschutzgerecht getötet werden alle
expertinnen und experten haben seit
jahren davor gewarnt nun ist es leider
realität geworden die afrikanische
schweinepest ist auch bei uns
niedersachsen angekommen und nicht
zuerst bei wildschweinen wie in
brandenburg und sachsen sondern in einem
haus schweinebestand im südlichen
emsland die krisenzentren in den
landkreisen wurden aktiviert eine
sperrzone von zehn kilometern
eingerichtet der transport von schweinen
ist in dieser zone untersagt betroffen
sind 300 schweine betriebe die massive
konzentration von vielen tieren oft
wenig raum kritisiert greenpeace neben
umwelt- und tierschutz problemen könnten
sich tierseuchen bei der hohen dichte an
mastbetrieben besonders schnell
ausbreiten das virus ist für den
menschen ungefährlich doch für die
schweine endet es tödlich die tiere
stellen spontanes fressen werden glas
bekommen hohes fieber und per akute
verläufe bedeuten dann auch dass sie
dann
innerhalb weniger stunden schon zu tode
kommen können nach den ersten
bestätigten fällen in niedersachsen und
brandenburg befürchten schweinebauern
nun erhebliche wirtschaftliche einbußen
juli bis september das ist im hessischen
bad hersfeld nicht nur sommer sondern
auch festspielzeit
gestern ging's los mit dem stück notre
dame nach dem romanklassiker von victor
hugo liebe eifersucht hass und
verzweiflung alles dabei eine geschichte
um den glöckner quasimodo die schöne
esmeralda und den finsteren ernst diakon
bei der premiere der stiftsruine war
peter theißen dabei
wenn vor der 1000 jahre alten
stiftsruine in bad hersfeld der rote
teppich ausgerollt ist dann beginnen die
ältesten theater festspiele deutschlands
in diesem jahr premiere mit victor hugos
notre dame schwerer stoff der aber wie
gemacht scheint für die kulisse der
alpen klosterruine
prominent die besetzung den bösen
priester claude frolow spielte richy
müller
er ist eine verirrte seele die dinge
macht die man nicht machen sollte diese
unterdrückung der menschlichen triebe
die man einfach nicht unterbinden kann
und wenn man verboten kriegt die so
auszuleben wie es natürlich wäre dann
wird's dann meistern unglücklich ich
kann dich retten
defekte dem und es ständig vor allem
bloß
rotterdam spielt ende des 15ten
jahrhunderts eine zeitenwende wie heute
vielleicht wirkt das stück von victor
hugo auch deshalb bedrückend aktuell
der schiller die menschen in all ihrer
unperfekt haid in ihren irrwegen und
schildert wie fühlt man sich wenn man
von anderen verachtet und angespuckt
wird und wie wünscht man sich
respektiert zu werden
bis september schwingt die glocke in der
stiftsruine bad hersfeld
von den sport leben beginnen wir mit
reiten und da haben zwei deutsche stars
im sattel heute leider kein schild es
geht um dieser bewährt und michael jung
die ausnahme dressur reiterin
disqualifiziert der vielseitigkeit
champion von 1 auf 8 zurück versetzt das
chio in aachen stand heute unter keinem
guten stern
isabell werth auf dem weg die deutsche
dressur-equipe vielleicht doch noch zum
sieg im nationenpreis zu führen
plötzlich das vorzeitige aus für die
mannschafts olympiasiegerin die
wertungsrichter entdecken blut im maul
ihres qantas die disqualifikation es ist
unglaublich schade aber das pferd ist
topfit und es ist eben schicksal ist es
so als wenn wir auch mal uns auf die auf
der zunge oder auf die lippe beißen so
gewinnt dänemark dank top reiterin
dufour erstmals den nationenpreis vor
deutschland und schweden michael jung
sieht auf seinem chip man wie der
sichere sieger in der vielseitigkeit aus
die sehr stunden danach von der jury
wegen dieses strauch last noch straff
punkte kassiert und nur achter will
darum darf sich sandra auffahrt auf die
a monkey maz nun szenario siegerinnen
ein bitteres drama erlebt die briten
rosalind kennt ihr weltmeister fährt da
verletzt sich an diesem hindern ist
unglücklich und offenbar unheilbar der
17 jahre alte hengst musste
eingeschläfert werden
zweiter tag der tour de france mit dem
sieg eines niederländers in dänemark
fabio jacobsen sprintet nach 200 2,5
kilometern in dieburg als erster über
die ziellinie
geschlossen gegen das feld auf die
spektakuläre 18 kilometer lange
hängebrücke über den großen belt dann
dieser sturz trotz der breiten straße
beteiligt auch yves lambert der träger
des gelben trikots aber der belgier
bleibt unverletzt findet schnell wieder
anschluss die entscheidung fällt im
sprint den gewinn der niederländer fabio
jacobsen vor dem belgier bart van aart
der wiederum sichert sich mit platz zwei
das gelbe trikot liegt eine sekunde vor
lampart tour-favorit adecco caccia aus
slowenien ist mit acht sekunden
rückstand dritter
für die hockey weltmeisterschaft der
frauen machen spanien und die
niederlande als gastgeber gemeinsame
sache das deutsche team ist in
amstelveen mit einem sieg gegen chile
gestartet charlotte stapenhorst von den
zehlendorfer wespen besorgt im
nachschuss gegen die wm debütanten aus
südamerika dem treffer zum 4 zu 1
endstand schon morgen abend wartet
titelverteidiger und rekordchampion
niederlande
und für die hockey wird mannschaft
hatten wir schon regen bei der formel 1
in silverstone das ist keine
überraschung aber dafür die erste pole
position der karriere für carlos sainz
junior der ferrari pilot aus spanien
schaffte in der qualifikation für den
großen preis von großbritannien die
schnellste zeit sieben hundertstel
sekunden vor titelverteidiger max
festplatten im red bull die deutschen
eher wie hostel pudel sebastian vettel
18 mit schumacher 19 von 20 startern
kann nur besser wenn das wetter
es ist jetzt noch mal richtig heiß
morgen wird auch noch mal richtig heiß
aber danach wird es erträglicher mehr
dazu gleich umwelt davon ist intelli das
heute schon mal können sie an diesem
abend um 23.15 sehen mit christian
sievers
[Musik]
schon gute amt und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter morgen wird es noch mal heiß
mit temperaturen um die 32 grad ja und
in der woche gibt es dieses hoch jedes
etabliert sich und so kommt immer wieder
kühlere luft an und das stellt sich
jetzt schon allmählich ein so dass wir
ganz im nordwesten deutschlands morgen
dann einige schauer bekommen im süden
auch gewitter schauen wir uns die
details an in der nacht gibt es ganz im
norden etwas regen sonst klart es
größtenteils auf und die temperaturen
gehen zurück auf 9 grad richtung
vogtland oder hessische bergland 15 grad
richtung ostsee und morgen dann im
tagesverlauf vor allem erst mal am
vormittag sehr viel sonne dann zum
nachmittag und in den abendstunden vor
allem im nordwesten dann einige schauer
mit der kaltfront im südwesten über den
bergen auch gewitter temperaturen
verbreitet über der 30 grad marke 32
grad gibt es im südwesten dort wird am
heißesten und am kühlsten richtung
nordsee bei 21 grad der blick auf die
nächsten tage montag im süden gewitter
ganz im norden schauer bei 28 grad noch
die folgenden tage liegen deutlich unter
der 30 grad marke schöne amt